今天是生态时刻的第60场
我们初中的缘分真的很不一样
2010年的时候
那时候我来这里拍
爱上查美乐
那他在杭州住了一个多月
然后到了2017年的5月20号
在杭州办了
我到现在依然记得
当时杭州给了我最大的温暖的拥抱
谢谢杭州
谢谢你们
每一位
新人的照片很可爱吧
这次跟韩国插画家合作啊
都会有啊
大家都会有啊
大家都会有娇娇姐
大家都会有吧
而且这次料子不太一样漂亮啦
刚换好的说听不到我说了
之前我们跑那么久
应该要出现一些番队什么的
然后我们现在也翻对了
但是还有一个愿望还没有达成
可时间跑了那么久
关于送子鸟的部分
今天夏至幻想开始
我不知道有没有什么帮助
知我莫若你们
我还真觉得有点热
而且阿德他刚刚想说跟大家一样往前扇
然后这样扇一扇
其实他他在扇自己
然后刚好那个猫们我眼神瞟过去
他好像扇自己车就变这样
我看的你一清二楚
然后你刚在台上的时候
你在跳这个时候
然后他也是就是马克马克跳
然后刚好我先走出来
哎看到哇马上又变成那个
这我也是很用心交朋友
读心术
他今天有那个surprise
为了这个我也大概练了20年左右
哎这是一条软软的丝巾
软软的软软
给他一下
摸一下摸真的是蛮软的
心灵可以摸一下啊
软软的啊
对对对好
然后呢肥仔就要看着
嘿
你是认真的
妈妈好好海美海美海美哦
还没来
太软了
两张纸哦
我们音乐魔法师杨白老师
今天为我们带来的魔术表演到底是什么呢
我们来看一下这个哇哇
很棒很棒很棒很棒
大家都非常的用心
然后每一个单位都越来越卷
然后像我们试训组啊
也是有信心
然后刚才刚才我彩排的时候
镭射组呢就开始来一些镭射的东西的一些哇
大家都是绞尽脑汁好竞争激烈
竞争激烈
对这个就是等于是我们自己这个TM卷起来的
卷起来卷起来继续卷起来继续卷起发
每一次没有值日生都是你啊
所以你要你要你要问一下大家
大家笑哈哈
OK那我想一下哇
哦给你五秒54321
OK好哇哇哇来了
我会说谁来到杭州
然后你们说王心凌啊
那我第二句说
所以我们都有好心情哇
中央对rapper来讲还好
还有最后再往下压
还有后面就是我说休克
hi你们说2.0
然后我说王心凌
大家说我爱你哇
谁来到杭州
王心凌
所以我们都有好心情休克海王心王心凌
欢迎
欢迎大家来到20个海子里的杭州展园
我沉进海底
深海底
♪ 你开来的船是铁达尼 ♪
♪ 我在了魔域中 ♪
♪ 需要绝对有你的病 ♪
♪ 你说猫下一次要继续教海鸥幸福秘籍 ♪
欢迎来city party
C哩C哩
要小心就可以
♪ C哩CINDY有快递 ♪
♪ 咿呀咿呀哟 ♪
♪ 失恋失恋来安利 ♪
你们怎么躺在地上
怎么会踩踩在地板上吗
一开始是坐着
你现在是静静很大
我本来要加入
我已经要加入了
那手准备牵着他就走掉了
八八在这难过程度比上次更强烈
所以我只能这样子
但是只有两个八
如果再一次会躺四个八
哈哈开玩笑的